we're now live chair
and just to recap those points then that
i've just read out the
instructions to anyone who's watching of
the fire safety regulations and the
introductions
and we are okay to proceed here
sorry andy pray our legal advisor
area planning manager mark
robert carmill governor's officer claire
philpott is here
she is somewhere governance officer and
samantha summers
is the case officer catherine hale is
the other case officer
there's none of the ward members present
so we'll move on
apologies for absences and substitutions
have we received any apologies for
absence
have not received any apologies chair
uh we've not i've not received any um
correspondence from councillor parker
okay
thank you do we receive declarations
pecuniary and non-procurement interests
by members
are there any to declare
sorry chair just uh for lee park he
sends his apologies unfortunately his
mother died last night so
what's last time yeah okay we'll record
that thank you david
i don't need to declare interest no okay
can i please now move to the minutes of
the last meeting
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
thank you roy thank you chair there's
just a very slight amendment in
minute number 7.5 that the word noted is
missing
from the chair noted that
all parish cancers have been invited to
speak at the meeting
if that's acceptable chair as a
non-consequential amendment
are there any other points of accuracy
on the minutes
nope in that case
can i have a proposal please to accept
the minutes
council raise we have the secondary
please councillor buzzfeed
we now have pleasure so um just now that
we're back online
shall we return to the electronic voting
if we can
yep okay i will
so members i will just open the vote
so if members could please go to the
modern.gov app and go to the plus sign
in the top right hand corner
of today's agenda and there you will see
the subsection of voting slash
attendance
and if you click on that it will then
show the vote in progress which is
colored in the light
blue color
um
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and there's eight votes four
and two abstentions
see notifications of any petitions in
accordance with the accountancy petition
scheme
rob none received yet thank you
site inspections are there any requests
for site visits
yes uh we had the brief discussion chair
briefing about council hardacres uh
request didn't we
yeah that's the only one i'm aware of
it's very early in the um cycle so i
think we said we'd discuss it again at a
subsequent
briefing yep site visits
okay are moving on
planning schedule of planning
applications
land east of council country medical
center health road east burgold
um over there can i ask before we begin
can i just
clarify with the council hinton that he
is staying on the committee and not
speaking as a ward member
i am mr chairman and it's heath road not
health road
slip with the pain out of here but never
mind yourself
can i ask this case officer sam to
introduce the item
please thank you
good morning this application seeks
reserve matters for layout
access scale appearance and landscaping
the site is uh land east of the
constable country medical center off
heath road in
east berghout there is an amendment
to the agenda the accommodation schedule
on page 29 is a is incorrect
on your table papers uh page nine has
the correct
uh accommodation schedule
the application site is shown with the
red uh
circle it's on land
east of uh east bergot
the high school is
just to the north of the site we have
the medical center which is adjacent to
the site
and the donkey path which is a public
footpath runs down here
you will see that this is mentioned a
bit within your papers
and also in the committee presentation
today
um outline planning permission has been
granted
for the erection of up to 75 dwellings a
preschool
a neighborhood hub comprising a swimming
pool
office space and a shop public open
space
associated infrastructure and
landscaping
this is the site with the high school
to the north and
the medical center is shown just here
we have richardson's road which shares a
boundary
with that western side of the site
this is the application site outlined in
red
and shows the properties in richardson's
road just here
the application site is outside of the
settlement boundary
which built up area boundary is this
brown line that runs down here
the public footpaths are shown with the
green dotted line
we have them here and here and then the
donkey path
to the south of the site just here
this green color just here is the area
of outstanding natural beauty
there are no listed buildings in close
proximity to the site
and the site is not within a
conservation area
looking at the site in a bit more detail
the site comprises two agricultural
fields
which are separated by a line of trees
down the middle there
there is a field access just at the top
here
there is existing landscaping belts
along this eastern boundary
and also to the south just here
there's also some landscaping uh in
around the medical center just here as
well
uh there's some mature trees that are
along heath road
at the frontage of the site
this is the indicative layout plan that
accompanied the
outline planning application the
swimming pool
shop and preschool are all in this area
just here
there was one access point shown um
when the outline permission came in
however all matters were reserved at
that stage
and the purpose of showing the access
point was just to show that
safe access to the site could actually
be achieved
at the bottom of the site here two
attenuation ponds are shown
and there was uh quite a bit of
landscaping along this southern boundary
that was included
on this indicative plan the existing
trees to the south and west
east of the site are to be retained
and also the tree belt in the center of
the site which divides the two fields
this was an indicative drawing and was
not tied to the outline permission
by condition it was used to demonstrate
how the site could accommodate the
development proposed
pre-application advice was sought prior
to the reserve matters application being
submitted
the layout of the proposal shown a
pre-application stage was not acceptable
and really was quite different to that
shown on the indicative layout plan
two access points were shown one here
and the other one just here using uh an
access through from the medical center
car parking area
at pre-application stage this access
through the medical center
just shows access to the
commercial buildings and also to all of
the affordable housing
which was put in this corner of the site
here the other access was really just
for the other
remaining housing
this resulted in a split development
where the dwellings
with the smallest gardens would not have
access to the public open space
which is here there was no walkway
through for the affordable dwellings
to make use of that space
negotiation went on through the
pre-application stage
and the developer was advised that
public consultation
should take place prior to an
application being submitted
because of the covid restrictions a zoom
meeting took place rather than a
face-to-face
presentation members of the public
felt that this was not sufficient
however because of the short time frame
from when the final court decision on
this site
because of the jr and the reserve
matters application
needing to be submitted the developer
felt that they could not wait any longer
for the covid restrictions to be lifted
the developer did offer the parish
council the opportunity to visit a
nearby development in great bentley
which is very similar to this
application in terms of the design of
the houses
the materials used and also the spacing
of the houses
and density of build two parish
councillors and i
did go out and carried out a site visit
at great bentley
during the course of the reserve matters
application
further negotiations have continued uh
with the floods team
landscaping strategic housing and
planning offices
this is the layout that members are
considering today
there are still two access points
proposed
they're both from heath road so we have
one just here
and the other one here
the first on the western side would
allow
access to the shop and swimming pool and
preschool areas which are still in this
corner near the medical center
the road has actually been linked
through to all of the development
development now so that all spaces
within the whole site is accessible to
everyone
the preschool playing fields are now
more
in the center just here which gives some
of the properties
with smaller gardens more space and a
nice outlook
the affordable units have been pepper
potted through the development which
gives a more inclusive development
so you might not be able to see on the
screen here but there is a plan later
showing
that the affordable dwellings are shown
in this pinky red color
the open space has been moved down to
the bottom here
there are pockets of open space around
the site
with the largest being in this
southeastern corner
there are other pockets here smaller
pockets there's one here
there's one near the preschool and then
we have
quite a wide swathe all the way along
heath road
and all this area here
the existing trees that separate the two
fields are to be retained
and also the trees along the eastern and
southern boundaries
the dark green colour are the
existing trees that which are to be
retained so you can see them along here
up through here and then this center
line just here
there's also some of the mature trees
along heath road
which are also to be retained
this color here the lighter green color
is the proposed
landscaping belt
just along here and also along the
boundary with richardson's road
uh the attenuation basin there is just
one now
rather than the two shona outline stage
is just here and we have a small
substation
just in the car parking area of the
commercial buildings here
a two meter wide footpath um is proposed
around the eastern and southern
boundaries
it starts just here and runs all the way
along
the field edge so that people have
access from heath road
and also just here
is the footpath that links with
the donkey track
it has been confirmed that the footpath
would be finished in hoggin and would be
a buff-colored
bound material which would be suitable
for wheelchair users
there are pedestrian links all the way
through the site
mainly along the access roads and
there's also
a footpath just here that links on to
heath road
so that people can safely not use the uh
the vehicular accesses
and just opposite the school there is a
zebra crossing proposed
that was secured by the section 106
which is attached to the outline
planning commission
uh this is a breakdown of the
accommodation on site
um condition 29 of the outline
permission uh required that a minimum of
30 units should be included that are one
and two bedroom units this was in line
with the easburg
bergot neighborhood plan there are
actually 31
properties that are one and two bedrooms
proposed
condition 30 of the outline planning
permission requires that 18 of the units
would be for the over 55s this has not
been finalized at this stage
and will be dealt with by a discharge of
conditions application
there are a high number of four bedrooms
properties on this site um
this reflects the very loose density of
build
on the site and um
reflects probably what people would want
to be moving to eastburgh
for the larger houses
this plan shows the affordable units
with the yellow
circles they comprise eight flats
above the shop nine pairs of
semi-detached houses
with two or three bedrooms strategic
housing have raised an objection
to the flats above the shop normally
our registered providers do not want
these type of properties
however the developer has entered into
discussions with a registered provider
who is interested in taking on the flats
the affordable units have been potted
around the development making this a
more inclusive place for future
residents
this is the shop with the flats above
on the ground floor of the shop we have
the shop area
there's a work unit just here a bin
store
and also access to the flats
just here with a lobby area here that
would be suitable for
storage of push chairs and bicycles on
the first
floor there are six flats
there's six flats at one bedroom sorry
and
two two bedroom flats
these are some of the affordable units
and this is another house type for the
affordable units
these are the three bedrooms affordable
units both of these house types have
traditional features with chimneys
detailing
on the brickwork traditional style
windows
and detailing above the ground floor
windows at the front of the dwellings
this design ties the affordable units in
with the rest of the development
this is the preschool this is a lot more
contemporary in its design
and has a split roof to break up the
bulk of the building
the building is quite wide and the use
of windows in the
split roof just here will help to light
the internal spaces of the building
the preschool breaks up the space into
age groups
internally with a baby room
a two to three year age get uh and a
three to five age in this area here
also within the building there's a soft
play area a kitchen
staff room meeting room and office the
covered outdoor play area
to the back of the classrooms is shown
here
there's also two playing fields to the
rear of the building
this is the swimming pool the building
would hold a
15 by 8 metre swimming pool a seating
area
with servery changing rooms and plant
room
there has been some concerns raised from
villages about the design of the
commercial buildings
however these are located in an area
close to the medical center
and the high school which are also
buildings with the design that is
functional for their use
five bungalows are proposed on the site
the blue circles
show those bungalows um
the three bungalows on the western
boundary on this side here
have been negotiated following concerns
from a neighbor in richardson's road
about
overlooking of his garden
this is the design of the bungalow the
design
is considered to be acceptable and
shares many of the features
that the affordable units have and also
the market housing so we have the
chimneys
and also some detailing on that front
elevation with the traditional style
windows
moving on to the market houses
at the entrance to the site the
residential part of the site so
access to there is a terrace row of five
dwellings
again these have shared detailing with
the other house types
these the terrace row houses are two
bedroom units
this is house type three which is a
three bedroom detached dwelling
uh house type five which is a pair of
semi-detached dwellings
these dwellings have three bedrooms
house type six which is a detached
dwelling with
attached double garage
house type 6 is a 4 bedroom dwelling
house type 7 another detached house with
attached double garage
house type seven is also a four bedroom
dwelling
house type eight is a detached two-story
dwelling
this one also has four bedrooms
and finally house type 10 which is a
detached dwelling
as you can see the development would
have a character of its own
that harmonizes together through design
and the materials used
all of the dwellings would be finished
in brick there's a mixture
proposed of buff red and a
multi red blend the roof tiles proposed
are artificial slate pan tiles and plain
tiles
some of the materials are not considered
to be acceptable for the east bergot
location this is an edge of village
location
and is sensitive in landscape terms
because of the aomb
a condition to agree suitable materials
is recommended
real slate and clay roof tiles are
required
as these will be the materials that will
be seen
at a distance until the trees grow up
along the boundaries
all of the market houses have either a
single or double garage
apart from the terrace row which has
open air parking spaces
this is the landscaping plan the green
dots on
are the proposed trees
there are lots of trees around the
commercial part of the development
this helps to break up the larger
buildings but also helps to break up the
hard surfacing of the car parking areas
all boundaries on the site will have a
green screen which is excellent
in terms of landscape impact but also
for ecology
moving on to some photographs this is
heath road
heading from the direction of brantham
into the village
the trees that are shown just here are
that existing
uh triangular shaped landscaping belt
that are to be retained on that eastern
boundary
again just showing you uh this wide band
of existing trees there to be retained
this is the tree belt just here looking
into the site
this is the eastern field you can just
probably make out that central row of
trees
dividing the two fields that to be
retained
and just behind those you may be able to
make out the houses in richardson's road
and also
the medical center which you can just
see the white render on there
all of this landscaping along here and
to the bottom of the site is to be
retained
this is the existing field access
just here and that is
roughly where the new entrance to the
site will be
this shows the existing line of trees to
be retained
in the center of the site
this is looking back towards that
landscaping belt
you can just see along here which gives
the site really really good screening
this is the western field just here
you can just make out medical center
again uh in with right render here
and the properties in richardson's road
to the rear
looking through uh to the western field
there are far-reaching views across the
fields and landscape
and this is why that wide landscaping
belt along the southern boundary is so
important to continue along
right to the end of that field
this is the medical center just here
and this would be the position where the
preschool the shop with the flats above
and the swimming pool would be
and also the second access into the site
this is looking towards the village just
moving on a bit showing the access
points for the high school
and the medical center
this is the medical center just here
the commercial properties would be
adjacent to this building
as you can see it's quite an ordinary
looking building
that serves its purpose as a medical
center
these are some of the properties in
richardson's road that will share a
boundary with the site
some of the affordable units and the
bungalows would be behind the rear
gardens
of these properties here
the properties in richardson's road that
share a boundary with the application
site
are a mix of one and a half story and
two-story dwellings
along this side here
there has been some criticism about the
design of the proposed dwellings
taking richardson's rose as an example
of this
consideration of the uh the properties
these are not historic properties
you could say that they they don't
really reflect the character
of east bergot in terms of its historic
core
but they do have a sense of design and
place
for their time
and the same can be said for the site
that you're looking at today
the house design is very similar for all
of them they share detailing and
materials
to make it a harmonized development
there are green areas in richardson's
road
which give a sense of openness and space
that reflects the countryside location
right on the edge of the village the
proposed
development is a lot less dense than
richardson's road
and retains its edge of village location
because of its spacing
and wide open spaces within the site
the large number of trees and soft
landscaping proposed
also add to that sense of being on the
edge of the village
the design of all of the houses tie in
together and give the development
a sense of place
the next few photographs were taken on
my site visit
the great bentley development which is
similar in density
house designs and materials as the east
bergot
development
so there you can see the big open space
some of the house types
and that's the bungalow type
this is one of the affordable units
however they are slightly different for
the use bergot
application as we don't have this
gable end so basically if you chop it
off there
that would be the pair of semi-detached
dwellings
and the attenuation bond uh just showing
how that's used as part of the green
open space
uh the principle of uh development has
been established through the granting of
the outline planning permission
members are looking at the layout access
scale
appearance and landscaping today these
reserve matters are considered to be
acceptable
and officers recommend that this
application is granted
subject to conditions outlined in your
committee papers
also a deed of variation is required for
the section 106
which needs to be signed before we can
release the
application as there is a
slight change in the housing mix for the
affordable dwellings
um as required by strategic housing
thank you thank you sam for that
comprehensive report um if the lights
come on i might be able to read my nose
thank you any questions to members to
the planning officer
council beer um thank you mr chairman i
want to take this off content thank you
mr chairman
um samantha um
you picked up a bit of my clarification
point
uh on slow 54 55 i think but great
bentley you said um
that you were invited i couldn't really
hear
to be honest but was that you as
officers or was this the local parish
council and local members or were
we as a planning committee invited to go
along and look at these
that was the first part and the second
question
uh clarification design of paul
i read about it on pages 37
0.7 7.78
regarding the designing i'd be
interested if you can give a bit more
insight on that and what the local
member might want to comment on that in
due course because
that does seem to be a concern thank you
yes thank you councillor b um
because of the covid restrictions site
visits for
members of the committee was not allowed
however the parish council were invited
by the developer to go out and see
the great bentley site and i did tag
along to that
to that site because it's quite hard to
sometimes to think how from 2d plans how
how buildings are actually going to look
and the space is involved
so i thought getting some photographs
for members might be helpful
during the presentation today
two members of the parish council did go
out
on site there were two site visits
actually
set up unfortunately some of the members
actually caught code
during those two site visits so
unfortunately
the second site visit was actually
cancelled because of covid
but two of the parish councillors did go
out on site
in terms of the design of the pool
it's one of those things isn't it it's
going to be quite a big
building because it's got to house a
swimming pool and all of the bits and
pieces that go along with that
how you get that to be acceptable in
design terms is a difficult one
we felt that the design was okay in this
particular instance
uh materials are to be agreed which
could help
uh with the building um but it is in an
area
where the preschool the shop and the
medical center
are all within visible links to it
and we felt that the the design and
materials were acceptable on this
occasion
well i'll just come back on that
particular point
so is the pool building
um very similar to what is already there
the
doctors the other things that you refer
to
um in terms of the scale uh the height
of it
yes all of those buildings are a similar
uh scale so
no higher than two stories um
they've tried to break up the building a
little bit actually by uh
putting a gable on one end of it so you
don't just get this
rectangle really so they have tried to
to break up the quite big surfaces of
the walls
and as i say for its purpose as a
swimming pool
it is acceptable
thank you chairman hello sam um
on page 19 um the document refers to
uh key worker properties are they
within that affordable housing
allocation
and how how would they be would they
just be is referred to the um east bergo
academy
would it only be for academy staff would
it be
you know adjacent medical staff or how
would that
operate yeah so uh
during the outline uh permission uh the
key workers
were agreed uh the houses for the key
workers they were actually requested by
the academy
um they are in the section 106. uh
there's
there's been some talk as to how we can
actually secure those
as affordable dwellings so
strategic housing and the high school
have been
having talks and key workers would
would have to register on the affordable
housing list in order to gain one of
those
spaces so all of that work has been
going on in the background so
um but in terms of key workers
of the medical center staff i don't
think
is necessarily for those is just for the
academy staff is my understanding of
that
councillor hinton
[Music]
thank you mr chairman i've got several
points in actual factors you can
probably sort of
ascertain from from my notes here um but
first of all
um viability is a valid item in the
affordable housing provision and
weighted in favor of the applicant
do we have any viability data for the
swimming pool community building
shop etc to justify why we should build
these or allow these buildings to be put
in place
without any real guarantee that there is
going to be a viable use for them
um that's first question uh a second
question whilst you mentioned a
pedestrian crossing which had been
secured by 106
on the outline that's probably one of
the very few things that were
agreed on the outline because everything
else is completely up in the air is
which is very unusual usually at least
have the access on an outline
application
but we didn't on this on it was purely
the numbers on the site and uh the
zebra crossing where is the zebra
crossing going to be put and what did
highway
say about that bearing in mind that when
the health center was built
a zebra crossing was proposed as one as
a 106 agreement for that
and it was turned down in the end as
being too dangerous
so why is it one being put in now and
where is it being put in because when
you look online
it's impossible to see exactly where the
the uh
zebra crossing starts from and finishes
those are the first two questions i've
got a few more mr chairman
thank you
yeah so yeah viability of the commercial
properties is something that has cropped
up through
the life of the application um my
understanding
is that those facilities were something
that the village wanted
when the outline permission uh when they
sounded out
for the land before they put in the
outline permission
um i don't know any more than that
a reserve matters stage we can't
actually ask for viability
of those units
as i say it should have been dealt with
that outline stage really
when i had the pre-application advice
with the developer
i was told the talks were going on
behind the scenes
for all three of the properties so the
shop the swimming pool
and the preschool and the interest for
all three of those properties have
had already been expressed by interested
parties
um i don't know any more than that at
this stage because
we're not looking at that we're looking
at the layout the design
appearance etc today um
in terms of the zebra crossing yep that
was a
requirement of highways at the outline
stage
i'm not sure why it was turned down for
the medical center
it is opposite the high school the
entrance to the high school
the highways felt that there is
a really big problem with these spurgo
on heathrow during school drop-off and
pick-up times
so whether highways are anticipating
that parents are going to be using the
car parking areas
of those commercial buildings to drop
their children off so that their
children can walk across
the zebra crossing to the other side of
the school rather than blocking
um the road i'm not too sure i did ask
for a highways engineer to be here today
but unfortunately
because of covered restrictions there
isn't anyone available
i think it's chairman just to come back
on that point the
indicated drawings that were brought to
my attention as far as zebra crossing
were concerned
were that it would start somewhere in
front of the
health center and would finish
on the verge in the middle of the
entrance ways
and exit points for the school there are
three entrance and exit points all close
together there
uh and that the zebra crossing would
finish in the middle of them so
effectively you'd be dumping children in
the middle of
the traffic a bit like putting a zebra
crossing to the roundabout in the middle
of a
uh a busy junction and then saying you
make your own way from there
thank you councillor you've made your
point sorry you've made your point on
that one
this is clarification from the officer
please
right and well to move on then
so highways didn't have anything to say
about the fact that there were now going
to be
uh three access points on the
south side of the and four
on the north side always the
multiple uh traffic uses not just
domestic properties
um in a extremely congested area so they
didn't consider that would be a highways
issue
um clearly they they did consider the
highway safety implications
um you're correct with the zebra
crossing
it does go in front of the medical
center into what is effectively
an island on the in and out of the uh
high school
how the high school deal with that from
that point will be up to the high school
it doesn't actually
impact on the highway which i know it
sounds like a get out
but um that that is how it is i'm afraid
um they would have considered all of the
access points
and whether they felt that there would
be a conflict uh
with highway safety they didn't raise
any objection
to this scheme
and the next one mr chairman if i may
just move on um
[Music]
as this is a reserve matters
and the initial uh outline permission
didn't cover it at all
uh have we got any detail on its
compliance with cs11 and
cb1 into sorry eb1 in terms of housing
need given the cumulative effect of
all the applications in the immediate
area
um all of that would have been dealt
with under the principle of development
for the outline planning permission
so cs11 would have been looked at
uh during that stage to see whether the
development was acceptable or not and it
was found
that it was acceptable and eb1 bearing
in mind that these bergholt
neighborhood plan which we've adopted
and accepted
shows i think 81 properties over 10
years and here we're talking about 75.
as i say all of that was dealt with at
the outline stage today we're just
looking
at the layout the scale the landscaping
access points and appearance
moving on if i'm a mr chairman um
page 20 21-22
mentioned eco diversity because
provision of
range rain water catchment etcetera
and solar panels are they are raid water
catchments and solar panels for
individual properties
to encourage recycling included and have
angling water made any comments about
the
uh portable water supply to the area i'm
bearing in mind that our own strategic
development plan
says that the whole of baby and mid
suffolk is under pressure
as far as drinking water is concerned
and the pressure in the village at the
moment
is extremely poor which means that half
the time your electric shower doesn't
work
and here we are talking about an
increased reliance on that
um yes i believe there is a condition in
the outline commission i'll just get
that
um and i think it is for a
sustainability plan to be
agreed
sorry there's quite a few um conditions
on the outline so i'll just go through
it and just see
what i can find
uh chair i think conditions four to six
are relevant samantha
in terms of sustainability that's what
you're looking for
yeah that's correct so thank you for
that mark
yeah condition 4 is
for an energy strategy to be agreed
and also condition 5 is for a build for
life assessment for each of the
dwellings
both of those are prior to commencement
uh conditions that will need to be
discharged
so presumably that former part would
cover the fact that they'd have to
install
air source heat pumps rather than gas
boilers
at this stage we don't have a policy
to refuse gas boilers but yes for any of
the energy
reduction in energy usage that would be
included in condition four
thank you mr chairman just to move on on
page 26
of the report i get a little got a
little bit confused
because
[Applause]
baba mid suffolk district council's
environmental protection air quality
talks about air quality around capel
well this is east berghold not capable
what's the air quality like around east
burkhart bearing in mind that there is a
measuring device on the four sisters
junction on the a12 which is obviously
closer to east berkeley than it is to to
cable
uh that is probably a question for our
environmental protection team
i'm not sure why they quoted cables and
mary
which is rather confusing when we're
supposed to be using this all this
information as to make a balanced
judgment on something
um
34 it talks on the internal roads about
what is meant about dead ends because
uh it is a dead end it doesn't go out
the other end it's not a complete loop
it must be a dead end but it talks about
it talks about
uh the exact wording of
just pull up says
internal roads to the site end with
houses and therefore do not provide
opportunities of dead ends
that are not overlooked and there is a
potential for crime to take place
um well there are dead ends because so
unless you're gonna drive through the
middle of a house
yeah so you're not going anywhere some
dead ends
so yes you're all dead yeah you're
you're correct they don't carry on
however there's houses
at the end of uh those at the end of the
roads
so that the end of the roads are
overlooked
and for vigilance purposes
some dead ends previously you will have
found
end in shared garaging blocks and that
type of thing
where crime could take place uh however
this isn't the case with this
development because we have houses
all around the roads there's nowhere for
for people to
to gather and do anything untowards
without them being seen
is what i meant by that paragraph
and next on my my list here
um page 39 there's no mention of opening
hours for the
to the shop swimming pool preschool et
cetera um
bearing in mind that we already have
three preschools in
east berkhold having a fourth one what's
it aim to do
provide accommodation for or children
who are
whose parents are on night shift or
something
i think it's probably unlikely but uh
it's a fair point
um and certainly if members were minded
to grant this permission
um we could add a condition for opening
hours
if they felt that that was necessary
and last the uh i
hope it would be last week mr chairman
something else pops up um
the clinical page 16 a clinical
commissioning group talk about
physical premises not staff to work them
the constable country medical practice
currently has
a patient population of over 12 thousand
um i know that because i did an foi to
them which cost me 25
quid but um i found out how many
patients they got on their books they
got
over 12 000 patients on their books at
the moment they have five gps
for 25 000 patients
the it's talked in here about there is
not sufficient capacity at the surgery
um for for to accommodate this
development as well
but building another room is not
actually going to help
in seeing a gp anybody who's trying to
get through to the cable to the
constable country medical practice in
the morning to get an appointment
um it opens at eight if you get your
call through smack on eight o'clock
you're usually 10th or 11th in the queue
and it takes a long time to go down
very difficult to get through can we
please have a point
well bearing in mind the increasing
demand for this practice in
the z 400 plus being built in brantham
500 plus being built in cable and 200
plus been scheduled for
for east bergholt have we got a more
concrete proposal from the clinical
commissioning group
as to how they're going to provide
medical services otherwise
the existing infrastructure is not going
to cope and the existing residents are
just going to
have a worse and worse lifestyle purely
so somebody else can have a nice new
house
yeah so unfortunately the principle of
development has been set
for for this site so 75 houses can go on
onto this site um the nhs would have
been
consulted at the outlying stage and
probably at that point in time
the numbers weren't quite as high as
they are now
it doesn't really relate to this
application that you're dealing with
today i know it is an ongoing book
problem and your comments are noted
well the mppf does say that we should be
looking at planning applications on a
cumulative basis
not just on a one-off basis so it's it's
valid from that point of view
uh and finally can we put
something into an application can i
appreciate that uh
we're screwed here anyway aren't we
we've gotta we've gotta grant this thing
some sort of permission because
we gave them outline without them
actually having to supply anything
in terms of what they were going to
actually do on the site
um but have is there some way that we
can put something on to protect the
ancient oak trees along the street line
extending from the health center along
there because anybody who's tried to get
out of our health center
especially at this time of year when
everything's growing
visibility splays are non-existent so if
they're going to
insist on visibility splays along there
some of those ancient oak trees are
going to have to be removed
and we do have a policy of protecting
and planting trees
the mppf has a policy of protecting
ancient trees
and we're just about to spend thousands
of pounds mapping the trees across the
district
so that we can decide where we're going
to put some new ones so
it's a bit hypocritical if we're now
going to chop them down
and to say we're going to replace them
is is highly relevant because a 200 year
old oak tree
has a good bit more carbon stored up in
than a sort of five foot whip
as you know there are mature trees along
heath road
some some of them may have to be
lost for visibility displays um
however none of them actually have tree
preservation orders on them
um sorry but the mppf doesn't mention
anything about t tree preservation
orders when it talks about protecting
um ancient trees um they are protected
full stop
whether they've got a tpo on them
otherwise we'd have to put a tpo
on most of the countryside just purely
to
allow for the prospect of somebody
deciding to stick up a property
somewhere
i think looking at the landscaping plan
i think it's fair to see that they're
intending on trying to keep as many
trees
as possible and also increasing the
number of trees
all around the site and
our landscaping officer did not raise
any issues about any loss of trees
on the site
thank you thank you chairman
chair may i clarify a couple of points
thank you um can everybody hear me
that's good thank you um
the i've been correspondent for
environmental control yes as a typo
counselor he said capril
um our office has confirmed it would be
the same response
about east bergot so that the
assessments were done properly the wrong
village name was put in
um in terms of health if members could
look at
page 15 16 17
it's a long answer from the from the the
um from the nhs
they've acknowledged the development's
not large enough to get a 106
contribution but have obviously asked
that the civil funding go towards
um increased capacity of the constable
medical center
basically seal is a mechanism here for
any extra money which they may
deem to be required for them so that's
their response to that question
and the business about trees that you
mentioned um you're correct it's not
just tpo
if more than a certain amount of trees
start being filled in the countryside
it needs a forestry licence so it's
covered by that
branch of legislation of your partner
that part of legislation
thank you thank you mr russell
council mclaren you'd like us some point
of clarification yes thank you chair
um i hope these questions are relevant
to this
journey of the application first of all
sam why did we not require
someone glows to be part of the
affordable housing
um i'm not too sure there's probably a
question for strategic housing whether
they
felt that the other bits and pieces that
were offered in terms of affordable
housing
were more suitable for this particular
site and maybe for the village in
general
i don't know because in in other
applications we have placed great
emphasis on bungalows
especially in a place i know you spoke
on
i mean people wanting to downsize but
can't afford some of the
more expensive properties it would have
been helpful to have some bungalows
yeah the strategic housing team were
actually
uh consulted on the pre-application um
so what came forward
uh for the application was based on on
what
they had to say at that stage and i
think because
there's um quite small units so
six one-bedroom flats and
you know that's quite a high percentage
really
so they felt that that was that's what
was required
just another question i hope this is
relevant
on page 39 you look on the list of
recommendations
of course of the construction management
plan
um how detail considering the proximity
of the academy to the site entrance
are will there be extra conditions put
on the
developer in relationship because the uh
times of course the construction times
are exactly
when the school is coming and going and
if you're in east bergal there's a lot
of buses and things like that
and all these young people and the
thought of all those construction
traffic the construction traffic going
into the site
seems quite a challenge really thank you
um yeah so on the outline permission a
construction management plan was one of
the conditions
so all of those details will have to be
agreed
suffolk county council highways will be
a consortee
to any information that is sent through
clearly they'll take that into
consideration when they're thinking
about the highway safety implications
but it is to be dealt with a later stage
not today thank you
thank you
councillor barrett thank you that's just
reminded me of a point on the conditions
so
one of the conditions talks about shop
opening hours to be restricted and
deliveries outside of those times to be
restricted um and the delivery aspect to
me would worry
if that was conditioned tightly would
worry me because
at the moment deliveries are really
difficult for shops to
keep maintain our food supplies um and
the location of that shop seems to be
reasonably far enough away from the
residences
to not impact on them so i wonder why
that really is
would be necessary i mean i i know
that at the moment because of it's a
huge shortage of delivery drivers
that shops are are being dictated to
that's when that delivery will come in
it's sometimes
five in the morning you know they they
cannot
they cannot get the supplies unless they
agree to that those those conditions
so is that really going to be necessary
or could that be
could that be um
give some flexibility to the the owners
uh yep we certainly could add into the
standard condition
the words unless otherwise agreed in
writing with the lpa which would give
them the flexibility
of having a written response from us to
agree
an extended time limit for deliveries
thank you mr jim can i just come back on
the point that councilman mccarran
brought happened
i wasn't sure of the answer regarding
bungalows
looking at this on page 29
it gives the doubt the dwellings and
they come to tow
to 75 dwellings they're all
houses from what i can see there but
when i go over the page
30 it says there's a mix that includes
bungalows one and two and a half story
it's totally confused me now so can you
explain that thank you yeah that's not a
problem so
um that accommodation schedule is
actually wrong in the report and
the new one is in your table papers on
page nine
um i'm trying to find that thank you
mr jim can i just ask can you just tell
me what they are then because
uh you'll find it much quicker than rvo
to scroll through all these
122 pages and then on to that yeah
so there are five bungalows proposed all
of them are two-bedroomed
bungalows five bungalows
all of them are two-bedroomed
where any of those affordable sam no
okay
thank you councillor
busby please
thank you chair um could we look at
slide nine please
so it gives us a second opportunity to
see the presentation again you see
actually that probably would have done
did you say nine
yeah yeah
okay so on the the eastern
half at the top there appears to be
a road that coming down from the curve
that seems to go nowhere and has nothing
at the end of it
yeah what's that about that's to access
the uh
parking for this row of terraces just
here
okay so that was my gonna be my next
question was um
where is the parking for the uh yeah for
the terraces and for the flats
and how much spaces are there okay so uh
the terrace parking is just here
um and the flats parking would be
in this allocated parking for the
commercial buildings
they don't i to my knowledge they don't
have actual
allocated spaces as such but the
developer might be able to
uh clarify that when she speaks how many
spaces were the
for the terrace i'm not sure that i can
actually see
well there's quite um on this plan i
can't actually see i'm afraid
it might just take me a minute to get
the plans up okay
can i suggest council advice where you
ask that of the applicant
i could well do thank you thank you
chair
applicant to look forward to a question
thank you mr chairman just one quick one
on the um
or two quick ones really first one on
the conditions
uh bullet point eight of the conditions
on page 39 of our
britain report that was sent out to us
shop opening hours to be restricted to
800 hours to 200 hours monday
so it's only going to open one day a
week
sorry exactly yes sorry that is clearly
a mistake it should be
monday to fridays
at one point i just find it within my
copious bits and pieces here there is um
another oh yes page 23
um question 8 in my on my list here
there's a barrier on the cup proposed
barrier on the car park entrance
will this not create a street street
parking in what
will be narrow means of access to
housing
and where's this barrier actually going
to be
i think the barrier refers to the
playing fields for the preschool
which is between two of the affordable
units um and that access is to gain
uh access for grass cutting i assume
uh but again
consider whether a condition requiring
access to the car park to be restricted
by means of a barrier
outside of opening hours might be
[Applause]
appropriate
paragraph 3 did you say
page 23 oh talk about something
um yep i didn't feel there was necessary
to have a
barrier for the car park especially
beings the flats are
are in that location i thought it would
be a bit complicated to sort out thank
you
any more council beer you wanted one
more
yes thank you um again it's just
something that's come up
uh from what's been said by other
members but can i ask you
these um plans reflect
the council's view and which i think has
gone forward certainly in the local plan
that we're trying to encourage
developers to make sure that the
second bedroom in the two the third
bedroom in the three
and the fourth bedroom in the four house
or flat
is um of a larger size it's not a little
box room because we we don't like them
we've made it quite clear
over the last year 18 months
um i know this has been ongoing for some
time that may not
be able to be written in but i'd like to
have thought that
the officers would have suggested to
them to make this
additional room large enough to be used
because quite often
they're not the second third or the
fourth room that is really capable
of getting much more than billion
nothing else
so um i'll put it to the
applicants but i'd like to know whether
it's something that we are pursuing
going forward but we may not be able to
on this occasion
but can you just clarify that for me
please thank you
mark might be able to answer that better
than i can actually
all i would say uh councillor is that
obviously there are national space
standards which
this application uh complies with and i
know i hear what you're saying but um
in terms of reasons for turning it away
because one of the bedrooms
is a bit smaller than we'd like i think
it's a it's not something we could
probably
fight appeal but what you're saying is
going forward it's something that you'd
like to
have discussed more and we yeah
sympathize with what you're saying
i i i accept what you're saying and i
take the point that we are where we are
with this one but
i do think we do need to be stronger and
firmer
to say that it complies with the space
criteria we all know that is not
adequate
and we we should be really pushing for
this to be
made more adequate so
it's just just a point that we can't
hide behind something that we feel is
not acceptable
and not really right going forward thank
you
council mclaren you have one more i have
sorry joe
um sam we when we looked at the
preschool
plan at the rear of the preschool there
was a protective
play area but when we're talking about
the playing field
what do we see as the protection in the
playing field for those
small children
uh in terms of fencing or well
i'm just asking the question because
they're playing you know i mean small
children if there's a lot of them are
going to
run over the place there's got to be
some protective measure
yeah put in place for the the playing
field i
accept the one at the rear is already in
place thank you
yeah um so i assume that it will be
fenced
um at this stage we don't have someone
that has agreed to take on the preschool
so i'm assuming
that ofsted will have certain
requirements
for safety of children and that will be
agreed at a later date
the developer might be able to explain
what fencing is actually
proposed at the moment certainly there's
trees and hedgerows
around there in terms of giving it some
screening
from from the houses that back onto it
but as i say it will probably come at a
later stage
once they have a provider in place to
take that building on
thank you chair thank you samantha
right moving on public speakers
uh as far as i know we don't have any
representatives parish
uh an objective or supporter but we do
have the applicant and can i invite you
to
address the committee you have three
minutes to address the committee
sorry how do i switch on oh thank you
my name is emma walker and i'm from
phase two planning and development
representing hills building group the
applicant for this reserve matters
submission
outline planning permission was granted
in february 2018 establishing the
principle of the development
and we're now seeking to agree the
details with this reserve matters
application
inevitably detailed design of the site
has led to changes from the illustrative
master plan submitted with the outline
application
however the scheme still provides a
similar mix of housing
with the same policy compliant level of
affordable housing
coupled with the same non-residential
uses a local shop
a work hub a swimming pool a preschool
and public open space
we have worked closely with the planning
officer at both pre-application stage
and also during the course of the
application
a virtual consultation event was held
with the parish council and local
residents
and the parish council were invited to
visit some of the hills recent
developments
the application proposals have evolved
significantly in response to comments
received from the planning officer
statutory consultees and
local residents these changes have
included
the provision of a road link within the
site so that the whole site is permeable
avoiding any sense of segregation
decreased
density and height of the dwellings
backing onto the existing properties on
richardson road
to the west to reduce the impact on
neighbours
pepper potting of the affordable housing
units
changes to the design of some of the
dwellings reorientation
of dwellings to provide surveillance of
the attenuation basin and open space
enhanced landscape buffers around the
site with car parking for the commercial
elements of the proposal set further
back within the site
and replaced by planting softening the
appearance of the
of the development from heath road
increased landscaping provision within
the site
including opportunities for street trees
and landscaping around the commercial
hub
amendments to highways design details in
response to comments made by suffolk
county council highways and a woodland
management plan has been prepared to
ensure that the areas of woodland can be
appropriately enhanced and managed
hills building group have a strong
commitment towards good place making and
high quality design
resulting in a scheme which can
successfully complement the existing
village
providing new private and affordable
housing coupled with facilities for
local people
to summarise this reserve matters
submission provides the details pursuant
to the outline consent in a
well-designed and sensitive manner
the scheme proposes local facilities and
a good mix of housing
both in terms of 10 years but also house
types and sizes which will make a
positive contribution towards the
housing needs of the district
i hope that fellow members i hope that
members sorry follow the recommendations
of their offices and approve this
planning application
thank you thank you can you just hold on
for
some questions
i believe you want to start cancel the
basically with a question for the app
it's half the most riveting question but
uh the car parking spaces can you
remind us how many there are around the
terrace yes
um so there's there's two spaces for
each of those dwellings
on that terrace um there's also some
visitor parking in that location
um did you want me just to expand also
in relation to the car parking around
the commercial
area well only if it's different from
what the officer said that
no no so i think there was just the
query about whether
um the flats above the
shop would have dedicated um
spaces and it hasn't been proposed in
that way it's proposed been proposed
that there's
um 67
shared spaces in that area that can be
used for the commercial
and for um the residential
okay and could you just
the swimming pool is that general public
use or is it just for the
for the preschool or how's it working
why would it
not be open greater hours than we
suggested
my understanding in terms of the um
swimming pool is that the hills have had
discussions with a couple of um
potential end users but nothing's been
finalized yet obviously
we're at this stage where we don't have
the reserve matters as yet
so there have been initial discussions
um
but that it would be for public use as
well as potentially for for the school
thanks for the beer thank you mr
chairman i've got three questions
um one five bungalows are better than
none
but um i'm disappointed that you didn't
have a few more
um and secondly
could you comment on the size of the
the extra room say in each of the
properties because
as you heard me say earlier they are not
usually
large enough to do much weird but i
accept that you're most likely
doing it to the space that is laid out
that you have to follow but uh i just
put it to you that
you know we are looking for better than
that in future even if it's not there at
this moment
um if we were minded to approve this
whether you're likely to start
and it was commented and i can't
remember which member
asked the question mr chairman about the
viability
but i think the answer given by the
officer was that there was
interested parties um
but i think that was more for you rather
than us
our officers to answer so can you help
on that one
i know you just say that the swimming
pool is likely to be
made available to the general public
which i think is excellent
but um can you just answer those three
thank you thank you mr chairman
um so just in terms of your point about
the bungalows
we have provided five um
i actually think that's quite a good
proportion you know given given the
overall
size of this scheme um in terms of the
extra that the size of the
smallest room if you like or the last
room
as the officers said that would be what
has been designed has been in accordance
with the
national space standards but
certainly something for us to consider
for future
in terms of start on site
obviously there are still conditions to
be discharged
but my understanding is that hills are
keen to
you know get get going on this site so
as soon as they're in a position to do
that and the appropriate conditions
are just a discharge sorry that that's
what they will be doing
and then in terms of the interested
parties for the
um the commercial uses
there have been some discussions with
interested parties in relation to
all of the um commercial elements
obviously at this stage those
discussions have only progressed so far
because
um it is difficult to progress that any
further without the
reserve matters in place however that
you know
those discussions um have been ongoing
and will progress further in due course
council
oh yeah um i want to get back to the
parking really where the shop is
um in the car park would they have to
pay
for the car park um or is it going to be
a free car park
because obviously with the flats having
to park there all the time
that's one thing and no gardens
for the flats nowhere to hang their wash
in
um things like that i know that's a bit
that's something to
yeah sorry
so in terms of the car parking my
understanding is that
no it would you know they wouldn't be
looking to make that a paid
car park so that would just be available
for people to use um in terms of
gardens for the flats it's not uncommon
that where you have flats they would
have shared immunity space so that's
provided
adjacent to that building so the owners
of the flats wouldn't have their own
private immunity space they would have a
communal shared space
which is typical typical provision for
flats
council mclaren thank you chair
good morning um
what proportion of the site um
is allocated for over 55s
thank you i do have that detail here
actually so
the condition um
on the outline permission required that
not less than 18
dwellings are for the over 55s
so it's proposed that that would be
followed through that this application
hasn't specified which those units will
be
it's just intended that would be done as
a discharge of condition
so those details would be submitted to
the council
to discharge that condition on the
outline planning permission
sorry my speaker keeps going on um
would that include then the affordable
housing
um i suppose it potentially could do i
would
imagine that it probably wouldn't um
but that's something that would be need
to be discussed and agreed at a later
stage
so in the light of that so no less than
a less than 18. um
it would be not less than 18 that's
right so it would be 18
at least 18 at least 18 properties with
the over 55s
in the light of that over 55
means from 56 to 96.
um what is the provision
of public transport down here
i can't remember actually the public
transport down
heath road what is there is there a bus
service
um my apologies my mind's gone
completely blank on this
um perhaps not quite a fair question for
the agent
john hilton can you just clarify for
it is on it is on the bus route if you
want to go to ipswich or colchester but
it wouldn't
take you to the village center for
instance it wouldn't take you worse
wouldn't take you to the center of the
village
no to the church or to the or to the uh
community physicists in there
yeah you'd have to if you got on the bus
say it would be it would be taking you
to which which your colchester
ipswich it doesn't go to the money tree
then nope
okay thank you for that and just
a final question about
which i asked the officer about the
preschool
presumably you would be requiring of the
contractor
to provide some protect protection
around the playing field
for the preschool absolutely um i think
as the officer mentioned there would be
that requirement from
ofsted in any event those details will
come
in due course once the
preschool operator has been confirmed
and that those details would be
confirmed and submitted at that stage
thank you thank you chair no more
thank you very much oh sir
thank you there's no mention of energy
efficiency or decarbonization
measures and i know there is a condition
you've got to
put that a scheme forward i wonder if
you could
enlighten on some insulation heating
that kind of thing you're going to be
using for the properties i don't have
that
information yet that is work that still
needs to be done that will be done
um to inform the energy statement which
will need to be submitted and agreed
with the council right so there's no
nothing available at the moment at all
not not at this stage but it's not
actually a requirement for this stage so
it will be submitted would be nice to
know that
okay
mr ames can't one last question please
thank you mr chairman um
barry you mentioned that uh it would
supply the housing needs of the district
and yet earlier on in your presentation
you talked about the specific needs of
the village
councillor beers brought up the the
question of
of bungalows bearing in mind that last
census showed a 20
increase in the over 75s across the
district
and i have figures here as well which
show that the
the old ward of doddnash which includes
burkholt and bentley
has the highest demographic of anywhere
in the district
do you consider that the mix of housing
that you're proposing here
is uh compatible with what
the demand actually is or is it just
going to soak in
uh potentially people with more money
from outside of the village
like for instance north london
i do think it is compatible i think um
we have provided a proportion of
bungalows but equally there's nothing
stopping
um older people occupying um
the one and a half and two story um
dwellings as well um
obviously we have that restriction in
terms of the occupancy for 18
of the dwellings for older people so i
think that has been taken into
consideration
that's about one final question please
thank you um
hello um excuse me um can you
tell us about any arrangements that will
be in place
to avoid people residents parking on the
grass areas
there's quite a lot of public grass
areas
and if people want to park very close to
their houses they often
uh park park in the nearest grassy patch
i think in terms of the parking that's
been provided
there is a good level of parking on site
it accords with the suffolk standards
so there's parking there's visitor
parking there's a good level of parking
um around the commercial area as well
obviously where it seemed to be
necessary then
measures to prevent people from parking
on on grassed areas could be put in
place
i guess that's you know real detail that
would need to be looked at
in due course yes i mean sometimes the
sort of wooden bollards need are needed
to prevent
prevent people taking that option aren't
they is that something you'd be
considering it's something that
we will consider thank you
that all thank you very much
it doesn't like me i keep going on
i will now move to debate council hinton
has decided to stay
on the committee and normally as we
start the debate we'd ask the ward
member to kick it off
but but i'd like to ask councillor
hidden permission to to get somebody
else to kick it off that we could be
cancer beer would you like to bring us
down thank you
we're just following on from the last
point made by councillor barrett
um regarding the park on verges is it
possible the officer can show us
a detailed map a picture
of the layout a bit closer up
because that is a very important point
that we create these
estates and families have
more than two cars as we all know
three and four they can't park on their
drive
or in the garage because they're already
occupied by with vehicles um
and so the only space left is either on
the
edge of the road in front of their hoses
usually two wheels up
the pavement
but in some cases they have lots of
grass verges
in front of their properties and
alongside and we all know what happens
they drive across and i think we need to
start to make a stand against this
because it is a problem throughout the
whole of baber
and i dare say it's in mid suffolk as
well that we
we need to bring it to the attention of
developers to try and
solve that problem um and because
we're just going to add to it and i
think it's most likely too late to add
in anything new here
but i would like a close-up detail
because
i think we will have lots of problems
with this
is that as close as you can get sam yeah
i'm afraid so
um so
all of the market houses have garages
and driveways
the affordable housing has
outdoor parking spaces i think
along this area here
uh there is a grass verge and the
footpath sits
behind that so there is some space
between
the road and the footpaths
i think it would be unlikely that anyone
would actually park on there
because the driveways are quite large
i suppose the only vulnerable place i
can really
see that there might be a problem would
be where the commercial buildings are
and you've got this public open space
along here
so whether bollards could possibly be
put
along there for example
during school times when there's a bit
of a scrap
for people to get parking spaces to drop
their children off
for school or picking them up
can i quickly come back on that i accept
what you're saying and i dare say we're
too far down the road on this but
is it possible that we could have a
condition put in
four boullards that it could be looked
at that if there's a
situation as you're developing the site
out that you're going to see areas where
there's going to be
verges and there's a lot of um
nearby house building which
could mean they'll want overflow spaces
that we put in some bullets to stop that
happening
um you know if it's if we put a
condition in there
there's a possibility that with
discussions with officers that we could
implement that with our environmental
people i i don't know if it's possible
it's just on the spur at the moment
thank you very much yeah i mean that's
that's perfectly possible
we've got the landscaping as a reserve
matter submitted here i think is that
right
if those drawings don't show the things
you're asking for
then we i think the simplest thing is to
put another condition on saying
notwithstanding details of
the applicant shall submit details of
stakes bollards whatever to prevent
parking on the verge perfectly perfectly
reasonable thank you
if i just come back again mr chairman i
think that would certainly be a
worthwhile
exercise and i'm not just being
difficult to this particular application
i i think a stand has to start to be
made and i think this would be sensible
if we can uh have that in and
perhaps work with it and see how it pans
out it could be beneficial
to everybody thank you
i'd like to propose that if we do course
that if we're
going forward with that um a
application to approve this and that i
can bring this
condition forward at that point thank
you
mark no problem there and i think we
ought to charge you
peter with having discussions with the
planning department to make sure that
the green versions don't occur again
well i certainly think mr jerry that's a
problem for all of us in all our areas
it's
something serious that's got to be taken
seriously
thank you chair um the um discussion
about
bungalows and i have recently read um
quite a bit of information
about this and research has identified
that it is important for those who are
over 55
to have sufficient exercise and if
you're in a bungalow and you don't have
stairs
you tend not to have that exercise and
it's important that you have that
continue because if you don't use it you
lose it and a lot of elderly people
um tend to not use you know their
energy to go out and downstairs i live
in a first floor flat
and it does me the world of good so i
don't think it's always such a good idea
to you know to have stairs can be useful
for your
arteriovascular activity thank you
mr chairman i think bungalow's um
well for older people
yes exercise i wish i lived in a
bungalow
unfortunately i can't get one in great
corner and
um i certainly walk up and down my
stairs and they give me exercise
but if you've got a bungalow you can
walk around the garden
you can walk in that room it's
absolutely ridiculous sorry
mr chairman thank you i think let's
try and keep the debate relevant to the
yeah
cancer baron you want me thank you um i
just want to go back to the previous
thing about the parking bays and i don't
know if you
can put up that slide again because
although we can condition
and put bollards into things i think
it's only
human nature you want to park very close
to your
your residence and i think you should be
able to and i think it's a little bit
contrived
for that terrace to have the parking
right behind it um
when those owners may feel well i just
want to park
right in front of my my property and i
think
they should be able to really um
not on the verge so i think i don't know
it's difficult to tell from scale and so
on whether it's possible that that
those parking bays could actually be in
front of those houses
where they will naturally want to park
um and sort of pull in
should we ask the opportunity yeah in
planning terms we don't really like to
see
parking spaces right in front of
dwellings it actually breaks up
the look of the place really especially
as this
is uh the entrance into the site
is that a road in front of those because
it looks like it's
actually a road not a path
i think it's near the this one
yeah right in front of the terrace
yeah that is um a pathway i believe is
too
small to be a um to be a road
uh this is the road here and the parking
is just actually to the side
so it's not far and you can see the
footpath link
going in front from those car parking
spaces
well i just think that's why we have
these problems because we don't make it
easy enough for
residents who want to park as close as
possible to their properties
especially because of crime because of
break-in if you have can't park near
your
your property you are a bit vulnerable
to break into your vehicles and a lot of
these people will have work vans
with uh tools stored overnight so
it does cause a problem if they are not
within
the media eye shot of the the property
so
thank you council mclaren you have
contributions yes i i just tried to
clarify in my mind what we are stumbling
with
the question that counselor owen asked
about the drying facilities for washing
for the flats and i can't
can somebody confirm what we established
with that
was that was the one or wasn't the one
could i have that slide back up again
please sorry
uh so there is a small area um of
immunity space to the back of the shop
where the flats are
just here okay
thank you thank you for that i i didn't
quite
clarify that in my mind thank you thank
you chair
thank you casa hinton
i think just as a point of information
as well for for the members
east berghold high school has a capacity
of 1500
at the moment 11 buses a day go in in
the morning and
out again and then come back again in
the afternoon and go out again
and at the moment they are virtually
empty
because everybody is being brought by
their parents in a car
uh and so the car population of drop
offs
has increased enormously but even
without that there is a major problem
along that stretch of the road
so any extra space for parking off heath
road
is going to be snapped up by parents
waiting to pick up children or
dropping off children so the areas in
front of the shop and everything else on
this site
are going to be inundated with
non-appropriate parking if you want to
cut termit that
so it's it's going to be difficult when
it comes to going up and down stairs in
bungalows
i have a stair lift in my house i
determinedly try not to use it
but sometimes when you're having to go
upstairs one at a time
by the time you get to the top of the
stairs you're a little bit breathless
so the opportunity to have something on
one level would be
much appreciated and if we built houses
of what is often called um
for life standards where you have the
ability to live downstairs
or to live downstairs and upstairs and
at the same time
then we would do away with this argument
about bungalows and everything else
but we keep on building conventional
type houses with bedrooms upstairs
living accommodation downstairs and
wonder why we then get lots of
applications for stairlifts
and people jumping up and down every
time there's an application for a
bungalow
thank you council here councillor busby
well it's unlike me to suggest that
we've been trying to over design this
uh application but it appears as though
we are um
you know over 55 houses i don't know
certainly they should need affordable
housing i think affordable housing is
really designed for the
for the younger element i can understand
as being for over 55s
and i think this is um
a golden opportunity that we may have
missed in that
the density on this site is is very low
and therefore i think there is great
potential for
a greater number of bungalows um
we don't often get it in in places where
the
as we'll see from the next one where the
application is trying to get far more in
to a site and therefore there was an
opportunity i think to use
to put more more buckles but look
i think the applicant has worked very
closely with the officer there's been a
lot of changes
from what was first put forward to what
we're now being
presented with um i think it
looks fine i think it's a an interesting
design i'm glad to see that there is
something other than just houses
on the site in terms of employment in
terms of
offers for the community we'll have to
wait and see whether they take those
offers up
but i'm happy with it um i'd like to
propose that we accept the officers
recommendations with the
added conditions that were suggested
earlier
well what do you mean about the parking
about the park
the way i see the solution to that i do
not like the idea of bollards
anywhere we've got them in cable there
are bloody nuisance concrete bollards
um they look awful the answer the answer
to
the parking is that you provide enough
space on the site for the parking and i
think there is
thank you
thank you i have a proposal do i have a
second
council hinton mr chairman i'm not going
to second it but can i just also suggest
to
the councillor busby that the shop
opening hours be altered so that this
isn't open just once a week
okay thank you
cancer osborne you were
thank you mr chairman yes i was i was
just going to second the
proposal of councillor busbees i i'm
in a complete agreement i think the the
officer has
had a marvelous presentation today for
us all
she's been sam's able to
be with the applicant and changed
quite a lot from the original uh
application and
and i'm pleased with it i'm i mean uh
concur with that of
uh councillor busby thank you thank you
council osborne
councillor owen you're yeah i just want
to compare who would be doing the
maintenance
of the car parking i'm just a bit
concerned that
they say that there's going to be no
parking charges
and then someone else takes it over
and then it becomes chargeable i'm just
a bit concerned about that
that's all we i didn't know
mark no we don't agree
no sorry we can't answer that
and you right cancer beer um thank you
mr chairman well
i'm sorry i'm not going to be able to
support this because of the fact that i
feel that
we should have taken the opportunity to
put in the condition regarding the
bullards they don't necessarily have to
be concrete they could be wooden
and they could just be perhaps raised
curbs somewhere things like that
um there's opportunities to do
something here and and i think we should
make a start but
um so i won't be supporting this thank
you
all right that's it okay
get mark just to clarify exactly what
we'll be both voting on
yes chair thank you the the request has
been for the
hours of use of the shop condition to be
include days other than monday
as in to correct that um and the other
one was to add in a condition
um for not withstanding the landscaping
drawings
um a scheme of stakes or bollards to
prevent parking
on the verges to be agreed
you agree with that i'm not limiting the
deliveries to the shop
there are the hours that that could be
yeah the shop should be the hours of the
shops would be specified i mean typical
hours of shock
i don't see any problem with that and
and again deliveries i don't see any
problems with the deliveries either
so so that's a three for
a recommendation about shock the
deliveries i know it was discussed chair
but i didn't get the impression that it
had been
accepted in any way
we have got the condition we could add
the wording into the standard condition
about the deliveries at times unless
otherwise agreed in writing with the lpa
which would give them some flexibility
if they needed to have deliveries say at
seven o'clock
are you getting all this um delivery's
conditioned to be amended
uh with a tail saying that's otherwise
agreed that's advice
mr chairman on a point of clarification
the officer
chief planning officer said unless i'm
wrong that uh this would include
restricted
park and on the grass verges
uh well that's that's part of what i was
asking for
um but i didn't think it was accepted by
um
cancer busby i i know we use the words
balars which could be
concrete wooden raised curbs
okay okay mr carmichael
chair i think uh to provide some clarity
i think there was a slight bit of
confusion in
mr russell was trying to help he read
out a condition that had been
pointed out earlier but was not brought
up by the proposer and second
so the point that was brought up earlier
about the parking advantages was
read out by mr russell but i think
unfortunately he'd included in the point
as that was not part of the proposal
that was made by councillor busby
executed by councillor osborne if that's
correct
yeah look i don't think it's necessarily
this like this looks like a site that's
got plenty of space and plenty of
parking space so i don't think it'd be
necessary peter
however if we're saying look you're
going to put a little
white fence up or something along those
lines something appropriate
but not concrete bollards or something
as heavy as that it would spoil the look
of the place
i agree with you totally that we should
stop
parking on grass verges except solution
to that
is to provide more car parking spaces
not
put obstacles in the way on the and the
existing space
boat council must be like something
something to point it towards something
like
wooden stakes that sort of material
rather than concrete bollards is that
is that your thinking looks appropriate
in the setting
i'm not certain stakes a little white as
you suggested a white fence or something
well surely this would all be consulted
mr chairman
uh by uh yourself um the
the officers and and and perhaps the
ward member
um i mean i'm not suggesting for one
minute that we go around planting in
lots of concrete
um posts and things but we need to
try and stop some of this unsociable
parking and misuse of the grass version
which ends up like a mud bath
that's what that's really what i'm
trying to say to you
if you're going down that road with a
condition mr russell
um then i will support it thank you yeah
just to clarify
what you'd be doing you'd be delegating
to officers to come up with a scheme
so it wouldn't be i mean by politeness
we could let people know but there
wouldn't be a consultation as such
and we could as an informative say
traditional materials such as timber
and not urban um street financial like
concrete no thank you that sort of thing
okay
yeah i think mr carmichael clarify what
we're voting on
if i can get you to clarify what we're
going to vote on thank you chair um if
mr russell whilst i'm reading this out
could you please send me some wording to
that effect so i can put that in here
for that part so i'll read out the rest
plus what mr russell will
send me in a moment so if you bear with
me one moment members
so the recommend so the motion on the
table is the application dc
2004 663 be approved as detailed in the
officer recommendation
with the updated housing mix in the
table papers
the correction of the opening hours
for the shop deliveries condition to be
amended
and then finally
um what mr russell will be sorting out
just at the moment
and that notwithstanding the details of
the submitted landscaping scheme the
applicant shall submit details or
provision
to prevent parking on verges
and the informative that this should be
traditional materials and not concrete
i'll just add that into the final bit of
my wording and then we'll be ready to go
to the chair if that's acceptable
there we are turns now complete so if
members could please go to the
modern.gov app
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner of today's agenda
and go to the subsection on voting
attendance
there you will see the votes being shown
in progress in a light
blue color
um
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is eight votes for
one against and one abstention so that
is carried
thank you i would propose at the stage
that we take a break
15 minutes or necessary
so
councillor osborne has a doctor's
appointment so he's had to leave
for this next one but
we'll carry on without him okay
moving on we are at
dc 2004 615 land off lady lane
hadley suffolk can i ask
catherine hale to present this to us
please
thank you chair and uh morning members
so before i
get into the presentation um hopefully
in the committee
report members will recall that this
application and the application
follows are potentially
linked now they can be assessed and
determined individually
um and but they can also be potentially
linked as a
as a land swap on the basis that this
seeks to potentially lose employment
land
and the second application seeks to
replace that so whilst i'm going through
this application
um it's worthwhile bearing in mind that
there is or see a second application
which
is somewhat linked to this but again
they can be determined
separately okay so this is an
application outline application
for the erection of up to 45 dwellings
in hadley in um lady lane off lady lane
so here you can see
you'll see the application site this is
lady lane road
coming down here and this is the
existing lady lane
industrial site
this just obviously brings it into
context um so you've got the a1071 here
and then the roundabout you've got
weaver's meadow
here and also the persimmon sites one
which has outline and
the the remainder of the persimmon sites
that are in process at the moment are
over here
and this is the industrial site and just
here we can see this
the star and a bit of concrete is the
the site
before you today so there's no
set constraints as such there is a small
piece of wall at the front which is
great too listed but otherwise
the site technically um in terms of land
landscape designations is unconstrained
and there's no public rights away
um again as i said industrial sites from
north and then you've got residential
on the surrounding edges so the key
planning issues um with this application
really relate
to the principle of development and the
fact that
it is an existing allocated employment
site
and going forwards in the emerging draft
joint michael plan
it is continued to be an allocated
employment site
there's also the consideration of
residential immunity um which i'll i'll
go on to
so in terms of context and mrs where are
we 30 or so
just briefly the the site the
application that will follow this one
so this is a wide concept obviously
you've got hadley here
the yellow dot is the the application
site
this is lady lane industrial estate and
then cobalt's farm application site
which um obviously i'll go through after
after this one
is over here just for for reference in
terms of context
so you can see weaver's media
development phase 1b 1
and 1b which will be along here
so in terms of the policy in the adopted
local plan
at the moment it is allocated allocated
under policy emo2
most or see it has already been built in
this lady lane industrial estate
but this parcel colored in blue is
is the site proposed and this falls
within emo2
at the moment in the obviously the
adopted local plan and you can see the
text here
going forwards in the emerging draft
local plan
um we'll see a smaller scale shot of
hadley and all the allocations there but
strategically you can see
here a misconcept triangle it is still
within
the existing allocation um so it's a
strategic
employment site and is proposed to carry
on that use going forwards
so in terms of a site the the land
ownership
falls off sea within the applicant and
they also at the moment own
this area outlined in blue and which i
believe
was the former kersey um sort of
trailer park as it were
so there has been some some discussions
as to whether the site could potentially
be considered landlocked
in terms of access from lady lane
industrial estate
you could potentially access it through
lady lane
and this site if it was vacant although
there is a drop in topography and it
does go down
however there's also an access here off
of lady lane
and another slightly more confined
narrow access in between residential
properties
here off oldham road so the site
is not considered landlocked admittedly
it may not be used for hgvs or
b8 type of use in terms of industrial
but it could easily accommodate
um what was formerly b1 now would be
classy office use where you just
have your you know standard
vehicles and pedestrian access outlets
at front
so this is again just to remind you it's
outline matters
with access and structural landscaping
to be considered but this is just a
perimeter plan
the access would be here off lady lane
this would propose to be sort of
cyclists and pedestrian access which
will appear on the slides later on
and again this is obviously just the
current area of land which is still
allocated for
employment and whilst it's vacant at the
moment there could be
applications going forwards for for that
site
although it's in the applicant's
ownership at the moment but there's no
guarantee that
it will remain in the applicant's
ownership or
um remain kind of unused going forward
so that's to bear in mind particularly
given a close proximity of residential
properties
whilst there's an existing residential
properties here and lady lane industrial
state
there is obviously a separation distance
particularly with
a number of these units you are being
used for um
24-hour operations with hgv movements or
potentially any any chemicals and so on
and
this proposal would move residential
dwellings a lot closer
to the industrial state regardless of
whether this was developed
or not so there is what we call like the
agent of change there is a potential
that
you know if any residential properties
are here
and they've suffered from noise
disturbance potentially any odor
disturbance but then this will have a
detrimental impact on
on the adjacent industrial use
so this is a sort of topographical
survey
plan and then landscaping plan which is
to be considered so it's structural
landscapes and not
um you know the boundaries between the
dwellings or anything but the main
you know main areas of landscaping here
so there's open space towards the
north west of a site this is an existing
kind of buffer that falls
outside the red line plan but part of
the blue site so that would
be used as screening but as i previously
mentioned the
site does slope northwards towards
industrial sites so that is
higher up naturally
this is just a landscaping plan up close
so you can see it so this would be
you'll see open space
here and then
the buffer between the existing at a
employment site
and this is the bottom half
they are providing and it's a
requirement from suffolk county council
highways
to from from a site entrance to provide
a footpath
down to the bus stop on this side of the
road as there isn't one at present
um so this just demonstrates or see
where that footpath will be so here's
also the site entrance it's the lady
lane
and it would go down towards bus stop
these are just some photographs so i'll
see this puts it again into the
you know aerial view but clear up so it
would be almost this green space
here with access here for their kill
access
and then here you can just about see
this would be where cyclists and
pedestrians can also
enter and exit the site um but you can
see how close
it is to chelsea um liliane industrial
state and this
current empty parcel but as i mentioned
before there is still
you know the option that something comes
forwards or miss for employment use of
some sort
given it is allocated and within the
existing
lady lane industrial estate
so this is the access proposed and this
is just aussie shows where in the
context of the site it's taken from
this is another access to the site at
the moment but this would as i said be
used for pedestrians and
cyclists and again this is was taken
from
and this is the view from kind of here
at this angle
um to show say this is previously was
cosy freight they've now moved to cobalt
farm site um but it would just be
dropped below where these these trees
are but you can see there's you know
potential for access up here
so the recommendation i'll see outlined
in the committee report
is um for refusal on the fact that is
strategic
allocated employment land and this would
be a loss and it's not considered that
the offset
of the application to be heard next
is sufficient particularly given the
fact that this site remains allocated in
the emerging joint local plan
and i think the late papers the four
members has
comments from policy who are also
that is their position and they do not
support this application
thank you catherine any questions for
the officer
councilman just a quick one for
for us members who have been on this
committee for more than a decade
there was an application on this site or
or
where the entrance is proposed for this
site
through the old builders yard for some
business units with accommodation above
i don't see that appearing anywhere
within the
history of the site
i wasn't aware of that it might have
been that it wasn't picked up on
our generated system so apologies
um but that may be a mistake or on my
part i wasn't aware
of that um and obviously the history is
automatically pulled up i obviously
have somehow missed that previous
application
um quite
yep so it looks like sorry i just had to
read the committee report so it looks
like potentially it was one of the
withdrawn applications of that one
you're referring to in 2008
um for the direction of that right yeah
yeah direction of 61. 61 units care home
and
two v1 office units that was withdrawn
in 2009.
okay thank you
councilman jameson
thanks um the recent
workspaces in industrial units agreed by
cabinet
for hadley i wondered if you could show
where they are in relation to
the business site on perhaps on slide
three
or four is that
for the persimmon scheme that's coming
forward yeah
yeah there's a nice in the area
you bring it up
this probably is the best slide for it
so this is the lady lane industrial site
kind of whether the yellow dot is the
application
site and then this is the persimmon
development here
more or less
so the there's i think office use coming
up towards the
top parcel of these these sections which
is employment land
and then it will be residential so it it
sits within
you know within proximity to um lady
lane and hadley itself
and it's also been allocated in the
emerging
draft joint local plan as obviously part
of employment and part residential
so it's just off the roundabout at the
top of lady lane yeah
yeah yeah so it would be i think the the
first junction off that roundabout
whereas when you get to lady lane it's
the second juncture off that roundabout
okay
thanks for being here you had a question
well i think some of it's been answered
by the last
question um but it's um
part of it is residential and part of it
is commercial is that
correct and if so have they done any
markers and exercises on the res
on the um commercial side of it
okay so the persimmon site that has
already um
in the process of going through that is
yet part commercial and obviously part
residential
this site is purely just for residential
of up to
45 dwellings it's
on the basis that it's an allocated
employment site and therefore the
applicants have been offering
what's known as cobalt's farm which is
the next application
as a land swap so potentially if members
were too
you know minded to a previous
application but they wanted to retain
an area of employment then the cobbles
there's a potential for cobblestone to
come forwards
to to balance out the loss
um but obviously with the cobalt's farm
site there are there are other factors
to play
in the fact that it's not allocated and
so on but i'll discuss those
when we look at that application in
detail um in terms of
marketing for the employment site i
don't believe there's been
any any marketing for any potential b1
use or other or
so classy uses um the agent has stated
that
they consider the site landlocked so
it's unaccessible in terms of linking it
to lady lane
and but there and also it hasn't had an
employment use for a number of years
so therefore it it makes sense for it to
become residential given that
you know given the existing residential
properties
thank you for letting me come back and
can i ask our legal
people surely if this is
uh commercial um usage
then we're obligated to get them to
attempt to do a marketing exercise um
surely or or can this just be waived
i didn't think you could i switched on
i think it's in all circumstances as a
matter of planning judgment you'll have
have
advice here as to what the circumstances
are what appears to be reasonable to the
case officer and making the
recommendation
i don't know if i can help any more
specifically than that
i'm sorry counselor
[Music]
am i switched on i think my comment was
simply that it it's
it's not it's not a very helpful one i'm
afraid it's the best i can say in the
circumstances that the
it's always it's a matter of planning
judgment based on the facts that are
established
as to what is reasonable what can be
achievable in the circumstances and
i think the case office has done her
best here that if i can help any
anymore on that point really
it's so um adopted plan policy
um em 24 is set out in the committee
report and i think it
is page 7374. that gives two options
in terms of um the applicant agent
reasoning as to why it should no longer
be employment and why the change of use
reason one is that they've demonstrated
a sustained marketing campaign
undertaking a realistic asking price or
the second option
is that the site is unsuitable for
continued employment use
um my planning of judgment and
professional opinion is that also they
haven't undertaken
one they acknowledge they haven't
undertaken one but they believe the site
is unsuitable
because it hasn't been in in employment
use for for a number of years
and they consider it to be landlocked
um whereas i don't necessarily consider
it to be landlocked because as i've
demonstrated on previous slides there is
access
admittedly potentially not for hgvs and
industrial b8 but office or light
industrial could go there and that's
what you know as my recommended
recommendation says the policy um
allows and states that it should retain
its employment use
um the agent who perhaps when i see he
comes to
to speak later on and any questions he
can clarify
his reasoning as to why he thinks you
know he can use em24 to say that it
should be residential but
yeah that's that's the reasoning and it
is out in the committee report as to
what what the agent needs to to do to
demonstrate that
it's no longer suitable or viable i hope
that
helps mr chairman sorry to come back
that's confused me even more because
you're saying that
it's not landlocked that it
is um considered by you to be commercial
um the applicant considers it should be
residential
if it's considered by us to still be um
commercial then surely they've got to go
through a
exercise um that's what i can't
understand it can't be both surely
i i don't think um i don't believe it it
can be both the
the it's allocated as employment at the
moment
in the joint local plan that's emerging
it's still allocated as employment
the applicant obviously is requiring for
you know
a change of use and to create
residential dwellings if you go against
that
my recommendation of refusal to keep it
you know so we make sure it stays as
employment
then then they can part of severe
dwellings regardless
but what i'm trying to put across is
that we're trying to continue its
employment allocation the agent are
justifying
the residential element to be acceptable
because they believe
it is unsuitable as employment and will
continue
to be unsuitable um or see if they then
go away
if members are minded to refuse this and
go with my recommendation if they then
go away and want to do an
exhaustive campaign marketing campaign
they obviously are in their right to do
that and they can come back as a new
application
with that to go against policy em-20 i
think is
yeah okay council bower
thank you chairman um can i ask um do
you have any
uh evidence of demand for commercial
sites at the moment in weber
in terms of the evidence obviously going
forward for the joint local plan
the there's already the agreed allocated
strategic employment sites and they've
obviously
worked out policy worked out the demand
that is required and these sites going
forwards
including this site because it's
continue to be an allocated employment
site are considered to meet the demand
and
that obviously we've got at the moment
and
if obviously there wasn't the demand i
imagine in the draft joint local plan
there wouldn't be
all of the allocated employment sites
that
that we'll see going forwards and we
wouldn't need you know
need to say that the persimmons one and
so on if we already had enough
employment land so we clearly
need it and the fact that it's still in
the joint local plan going forward
shows that you know it's required
council jameson
the is there is i think there's an empty
space
to the north east next to the plot of
land
and i think you pointed that out earlier
if there is is there not access
available for hdbs by that plot of land
to the area so the the area that was
outlined in blue which is owned by the
applicant
um i think because of the topography of
the site
um it would make hgv access through
lady lane and down onto the site um i
don't think it would necessarily be
impossible but i don't think it would be
um it would be quite as easy or
beneficial as the existing
existing lady lane industrial estate but
that doesn't mean that it can't be
a different employment use um i would
say formerly b1
it's now class e and car c has a whole
host of different
you know options but it could
potentially have a b1 use where it's not
needed
access directly through lady lane but
it's not impossible
that you know should that site be
adjacent
and this site come forwards as a parcel
together for something it wouldn't be
impossible to to join the two through
the existing
following on from that um i think on two
sides
possibly three that's surrounded by
residential development is that correct
and
would we want to encourage hgv
and i take your point that you've just
said that it may not necessarily be
those large
vehicles but at the moment they could
would we want to encourage them down
lady lane and into this site
in the middle of a residential area i
mean we
we have tried to remove this in lots of
places and successfully
um so i'm a little bit concerned about
the definition here well because the the
site is relatively clear
any um any proposals for any future
employment news will need
planning permission and therefore see
depending on the proposed use
and the potential vehicle movements that
would be assessed at the time
but no we wouldn't advise htvs you know
going past the industrial site and
into this into this um you know parcel
land and also
given the existing access um that there
isn't
sufficient room for to you know a
vehicle in and little out
there the they could use lady lane
industrial estate
and come in from the north and access
the site but as you say that the site is
still then closer to
existing residential properties so
residential immunity would come into
into play but until an application is
before us that would be purely
speculative as to
potential options and how much of an
impact that would have on residential
immunity that already exists
hey council mclaren thank you chair
i just kathleen i just want to be clear
so the
on the map the
blue the one that was blocked out in
blue
that is owned by the applicant as well
yeah that's correct
so i'd are we expecting any application
on that then
at a future date i could i couldn't say
it might be one for
the agent or potentially the applicant i
don't think it's relevant yeah
yeah i just want to all right thank you
sorry joe
councillor buzzfeed can you put the
the picture of the site up again please
catherine is as possible
yeah which one
um well not that one
yeah that'll do any one of those okay
let me get to
you pressed through two minutes anyway
um
well this is why you should have had a
site visit because i went there last
night
and drove around it and saw i mean i
know lady lane anyway but um
visited the site walk around it walked
up oldham road
etc so i now know what it looks like and
what it feels like
and the answer you wouldn't be asking
these questions if you'd had a site
visit
access from lady lane is almost
impossible it could be done through that
kind of what looks like a grey blob but
there's quite a considerable height
difference between
the lady lane industrial estate and that
other piece of
land that's under proposal now
access is from lady lane it's possible
but as catherine said you probably
wouldn't want to drive an hgv down there
but there again you probably wouldn't
want to drive an htv down lady lane and
turn into anywhere because it's quite a
steep hill
but that doesn't mean that that rules
out every
aspect of employment there are still
employment
alternatives that you could use that
don't require hgvs going in there
it's not as you can see there it's
primarily
bordered on this on the western side by
houses along oldham lane
they're fairly old it's a fairly old
road oldham lane there's
parking both sides of the road on the
road
so access would be very difficult
into the site from oldham road
you'd have to go through lady lane
there is a considerable drop to me it's
it's a buffer zone
it's it's exactly got its right
allocation as it is now i wouldn't want
to see houses in there or
employment it provides a natural buffer
between the houses and oldham road and
the industrial state
and yes there are that's the building
that one there yes stop that is a
chemical
company and there is quite a strong
smell there when i was there last night
don't know what it was glue or paint or
thinners or whatever but there is quite
a strong smell of chemicals around that
side
again probably wouldn't want to live
around it but
that's that was just my observations
from a visit
so that wasn't the question for the
officer then
that's correct that was a question to me
wasn't it thank you
any more questions for the officers that
is relevant
no thank you very much catherine
carry on um can you remind us what
paragraph 127
is about because i think it's referred
to in your papers
and it's relevant to this application
i believe paragraph 127 is for me mppf
which give me um a minute or two to pull
up the mppf because i can't
i will admit i can't remember all the
paragraphs from the mps
off by heart um i'm not sure if anyone
could but you don't respect to be
challenged on that one
okay so it's planning policies and
decisions
should ensure that developments will
function well and add to the overall
quality of the area not just for the
short term but over the lifetime of
develop
development sorry they are visually
attractive as a result of good
architecture
layout and appropriate and effective
landscaping sympathetic to local
character and history including the
surrounding built environment and
landscape and setting
establish and maintain a strong sense of
place optimized potential of a site
to accommodate and sustain an
appropriate amount and mix of
development
um and then obviously create places that
are safe
from crime and so on um so it's it's to
do with the overall kind of
design of the site that policy in terms
of
what's all-encompassing
thank you catherine i think we'll let
you get away at this time
thank you moving on public speakers
there's no representatives of a parish
or an objector
we have leslie short as an agent for the
applicant
so you have three minutes to address
them i don't need to tell you do i
no
the right hand side one
no
[Music]
oh here we are it's working now thank
you
good morning members of the committee
i'm leslie short of artisan planning and
i represent the applicants for both this
application and that for the replacement
employment land
proposed as an extension to cobble's
farm i want to turn straight to the
officer recommendation for refusal
before you today
for this application for the lady lane
site and listed on page 82 of your
report
and to address the two reasons in turn
the first says
no housing need because of the housing
land supply in the wider paper district
can i draw the committee's attention to
the housing needs analysis for hadley
submitted by the applicant
applicant which demonstrated exactly the
opposite
this detailed assessment concluded that
there will be a residual need for
housing in hadley
over the next five years over and above
that which is being delivered
of around 150 to 200 dwellings
we've demonstrated that there will be an
ongoing local housing need for hadley
which will not be met and so a sound
planning reason to approve this
application
nowhere in the offices report have i
seen that assessment countered
turning to the second limb of refusal
reason one and
the specifics of the application site it
is laying dormant for over 15 years
its origin as part of the lady lane
industrial estate is historic
in that it once was accessed through the
main part of the estate
and that connection was lost some 15
plus years ago
it is physically separate and distinct
from the rest of the industrial estate
and as part of the allocation now only
has the land into oldham road as an
access
and that is spectacularly inadequate for
the purpose
that section of the site which fronts
lady lane is not part of the employment
allocation
and never has been and nor it is in the
council's new draft plan
in terms of its topography it is
physically disconnected from ladyline
allocation
which is set at a much higher level and
there is no possibility of a connection
between the two
this is accentuated by the presence of a
two meter high landscape bund
present on top of the scarp face
required as a condition of the planning
for the use of the higher placed land
so what you what you see here is an
example of an absence of any planning
analysis of the true potential of this
site
to realize and deliver the council's
employment land allocation
and that slothful planning resulting in
the repetitive allocation of the lady
lane industrial estate
over 15 years and through successive
versions of the cancer's local plan
is the reason that this land still sits
there today as it will do
at the end of your next local plan
unless you get to the real position as
it exists today
the second reason for refusal relates to
the juxtaposition
of the main body of the estate in new
housing all i say to that
is that we've produced every assessment
that we've been asked for and there are
no technical objections from any of your
specialist officers
on noise odour or any other form of
pollution
i urge you to either approve the
application as submitted
or to defer it so that the committee can
undertake a site inspection
and see and understand how the site can
never be a realistic part
of the council's strategically important
employment land allocation
thank you
thank you um
don't know whether i'd miss what you're
saying because you still got your face
mask on
might it might have covered it but um
did you
have you considered and why have you
ruled out
uh marketing the site as a commercial
site
can i
your question is predicated upon
an understanding and interpretation of
your policy m24
and that requires demonstration that the
site is no longer suitable for
employment use either by marketing or by
a viability exercise
okay we wrote to your planning officer
back in january
and said we're happy to rely upon the
viability exercise of that limb
to demonstrate that viable development
is not possible
and we do not do so on the basis that a
report
that was commissioned by this council of
aspen or verdi
in connection with your sill assessment
in the letter that we sent to your
officer back in january
it concluded or if you like quoted
paragraphs from the viability assessment
of development and labor
to justify your your sill regime
it says paragraphs es19 and 8.4
retail and office development are
unviable and industrial development
marginally viable paragraph 7.12
our viability testing results for
convenience and comparison retail
are set at appendix 8. our results show
that all retail scenarios
are unviable paragraph 7.13 our
viability testing results for industrial
and office
use are set out in appendix 9 our
results show that office development is
currently on viable on a speculative
basis
and so it goes on we pointed out that
your own evidence says
development to hadley on this site of
any employment character
any employment type is not viable
so no we haven't gone on to to conduct
a fruitless marketing exercise on a
development of a site that's not viable
okay thank you
any more questions
counselor beer um thank you mr just
following on from that point es19
that you referred to um
obviously is referring to the
unviability
of pursuing it as an industrial site is
that correct
yes and if
we are minded to refuse this this
morning
um are you likely to
try and see if you can get some
commercial use
or are you past that stage
we agree with your own evidence your own
aspirin alberta report the development
of this site
and development for offices which is the
one
b1 use that catherine referred to is
still being potentially viable
we prefer the evidence of your experts
that says it's not viable
so no we're not likely to move forward
with that and that might
sound like a bit of a conundrum compared
to what we're proposing in the next
application at cobbles farm
but there are massive differences
between the character of the site
here right and the cobblestone i think
you've answered the question
you're straining into the next
application
um some of the statements made by your
um planning officer today um
i'm sorry you've had your three moves
okay there are factual inaccuracies
in what was reported today
any more questions to the agent
trying to buzz me um 32.1 dwellings per
hectare
given the difficulty of the site and its
surroundings do you not think that's
too heavy a density
i think it's quite a modest density by
contemporary standards
any more no okay thank you very much
moving on we have no ward member
so in that case there's no one member to
address this and no
communication problem i'll open
things up for debate would someone like
to start
country beer well mr chairman just
really is trying to get something
underway i
know that the tone counts of hadley uh
are not against it um which i can
understand because
um councillor barrett and i did actually
drive by
this morning we looked at the site and
overgrown an absolute mess that's not a
reason for
giving plan permission but certainly in
the center of the town and i think
perhaps um we can't just dismiss it
out of hand i'm not sure whether what's
proposed is the right course of action
whether there should be a deferment
until we can get a site inspection
or that we
try and get one sooner rather than later
that might be a way forward
i don't know what other members think
thank you
um perhaps we could have a response from
the senior planning officer or
catherine on the the viability
that the applicant just spoke about of
the site and
because that does seem to conflict
rather with the
the policy of retaining that as an
employment site in the local plan
i think that's probably best for mark
that one
thank you chair so so the applicant has
put forward a viability
argument and quoted a document which was
submitted
by aspinal verdi and this hasn't been
part of the
application discussion thus far so i'll
be honest with you that has
slightly confused matters um
going back to the land use elements of
this
um hadley we feel has had
enough housing allocations 600 plus uh
mr pierce has some rather major sites
there's a lot coming up with jlp
so does it has it got some residual need
the applicant says yes we say no
um in terms of juxtaposition to housing
the existing industrial uses are i
understand b2 heavy industrial uses so
chemical
and bleach manufacturing that sort of
thing so that's another issue with
even if we if we accepted that
a b-1 type office use wasn't viable
could we put houses next door to those
uses that's another issue
so in terms of that's not really i'm
sorry we've got we've got nothing to
respond to our
chair at the moment
thank you chair um it's not often in
planning that we get comments from
the um police but i was quite concerned
on page 48
about not all properties will have
allocated garaging
parking areas and concern they're far
too back
for surveillance so i found that quite
worrying i don't know why the members
think
any other comments that anyone wants to
make
council mclaren yes chair
i just um following on from councillor
barrett
i would like to see more evidence of
this conflict in discussion we're having
about
the viability of the site i don't feel
satisfied
that i um we'd received
sorry mark a response really
about the viability of the site
the vulnerability of the site is what as
employment um we've had it we've had two
points of view one given by the officer
and one given by the applicant about the
vibe the
the viability of employment where the
the applicant is saying
he's received evidence that the
site is not viable for employment use
mark would you like to respond
i'm afraid i didn't hear all of that
count so sorry my hearing's not very
good at the moment could you repeat that
please
you were concerned about the viability
of it as as
business i'm a bit confused with the two
points of view
one put by the officer and one put by
the applicant
on the viability of the site for
employment use
um what
and we we've not received that evidence
have we
uh no i mean certainly not um i think
probably
it's it's not unusual for an applicant
to come up with some
an argument app committee one
understands that um i draw your
attention to the
table of papers page
page 12 onwards where strategic
basically policy again strategic
response and
that's our policy position and that's
where
decisions begin and end unless other
material considerations dictate
otherwise
now even if we were to have some nagging
doubt
that there might be a viability argument
we've expressed two other reasons why we
think that this isn't suitable for
housing anyway
one of them is that there's a lot going
on in hadley anyway that of course
there's never a ceiling but
the argument that more housing is
leading in hadley is not agreed with
and the second point is the
non-conforming uses which would be next
door to these houses
so the argument would not appear to be
very strong to go against the local plan
um and the answer from policies
articulated on page 12 13 et cetera
where they
are in principle against
this application thank you mark thank
you
thanks a bit mr chairman
i'm a bit um confused on on this because
i i like councilman mccarron i'm quite
concerned about the viability side of it
and there's two points of view
i mean in fairness to the applicant and
i accept that they will
say lots of fins and put forward things
but he had quoted es19
and he's explained it in detail to us um
i'm not happy that we have enough
information on this and
i would go as far as to say that we
should defer and get more information
and bring it back on on these points
and i accept that the chief officer has
quoted a couple of other reasons but
never
have i heard put forward before
well hadley's had so many houses we
shouldn't build anymore basically which
is what you're saying
um i'd like to say that in great corn in
long melford in
sudbury in lots of areas i don't think
that's a reason
and i can't remember what the other
reason was that you put forward mark
but no members i think we should have a
deferment
and possibly a site inspection in the
very near future
and they will be coming back very soon
and so
it's been delayed over 15 16 years
another three or four months isn't going
to make a lot of difference
and fail in that it's just going to end
up as an eyesore
and so even we need to address it
correctly and i don't think we've got
all the facts
so i'll propose a deferment
do we have a second level deferment
council barry you're just coming
yes um i think it is rather confusing
for us
um with this uh talk of viability that
is
uh suggested that it that's come from
our offices i don't know
i can't verify that i can't seem to
verify that so i'd like to
see another opportunity to to get that
information
any other comments answer both of you
i think it's right that we do defer i
think we do need a site visit as well
um my concern is the scale
i think whether you go for an employment
site or a residential site
the scale of what's being proposed is
too great for that particular site
it doesn't allow
the issues to be overcome in terms of
the the odors the imposingness of the
uh industrial estate the drop in
um height between the two sites
um the overlooking of oldham lane
housing although they've got fairly big
gardens
so
and i think from in terms of the
employment use
times have changed in 15 years jesus
look what's happened in the last 12
months
i'm not certain that we know what
is going to be required in the next
12 months for 5 years 10 years
i mean babe has taken on that particular
piece of land at the top of lady lane
because they believe that there are
there's a demand for those kind of units
if there's a demand at the top of lady
lane then maybe there's a demand halfway
down it
we don't know that um i think
until you know over the next six months
things will become clearer but if not
then perhaps we ought to
establish whether there is a demand or
not
it is an employment site at the moment
although i wouldn't want to see too much
on there because that will damage the
houses
on oldham lane it's an ideal buffer zone
but you guys need to see that and
appreciate that for yourselves i think
so i think yes deferring it
with a site visit and maybe the
applicant could consider
alternatives in terms of reducing the
scale of it
to make it more attractive so
yeah okay any other comments
jeff if
mclaren yes i i just would support what
my colleagues have said
i just feel in
the area of planning we've got to be as
transparent as possible
as a council and i just want to be
satisfied
probably with a site visit but i just
want clarification around the evidence
that was produced by the application or
the
presentation that was put by the
applicant differs
from our our sort of perspective of it
thank you thank you councilman cameron
yes thank you chad just to clarify to
council libya i wasn't saying there's
enough housing just saying
we're going against local against policy
there has to be a good reason for and
that reason wasn't fair to be strong
enough
and the other reason was the neighboring
uses are not conforming
next to residential premises um i wanted
to say chair also that obviously the
the jlp joint local plan examination
public begins next week
um and this site is allocated as
employment for that so
that comes after this aspirin 30
submission so the policy team's aware of
things that being submitted and is still
promoting this for employment
so would be going against the existing
and the proposed
local plan were we to approve
well at this stage we're not we're we're
we have
a motion for deferral
proposed in secondary and
we are happy we'll move to a vote on
that
and can i summarize exactly what that
would be that would be deferral
to allow the chief planning officer to
arrange a site visit
on the side um with the new
procedure or the new rulings for cycles
that's in place
that's that's a risk assessment there's
a risk assessment the new risk
assessment for site visits
yep can be word the
proposal that way are you happy with
that
we did want more information on the
viability side
yeah i think you did we have to have a
deferral with with an arrangement to go
on to a site visit
then we can talk about that so i'm
understanding that um there is the
a deferral chair for the chief planning
officer to
undertake a risk assessment for a site
visit for members to arrange a site
visit
bearing in mind that there is a new uh
uh photograph new protocol in place
for certain so or there will be by the
time you get around to it but don't
okay we use those words that effect yeah
and the other point is you would like
a response to the
viability assessment from aspirin or
verdi
you want do you want to include that in
this you want members to respect your
offices to respond to that
okay i'm very happy with that
okay
coming back to us again
mr chairman there's time for all um
parties to
to look at that and think about it
okay yeah the committee report would be
this one but with some bold text at the
top of it to let you know what's changed
okay
the second application i think that
we're about to discuss i don't know
well we have to choose one separate one
we can move to defer as soon as we open
up
i suppose um before the debate has
started can we elect not to just
to just not debate it can that be done
how do you do that um we can do it then
yeah i i think we we have to take this
this boat for this application now
are we all we're all set with what that
is
now we all need to get back into our
computers
who said computers would speed things up
sorry cherry you're waiting for me
either clear
i'll send it across you sir you've you
good
hmm
are we ready almost okay thank you
so chair as this will be your first site
visit
your new chairmanship will you continue
the
tradition of treating the committee to
cakes and
coffee at a calf of your choice
no
that's why he's the old one
[Music]
because i like cakes david
i know
okay thank you chair you ready
members the vote now reads
application dc 2004 615 be deferred in
order for the chief planning officer to
arrange a member site visit following
the protocol and for officers to provide
a response
to the aspirant birdie viability
assessment
if you go to your modgov app
click the plus sign in the top right of
the gender screen and select attendance
and voting
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda item will now show in blue
wow
thank you members chair that's eight
votes
four and one against and we
don't have council osborne here anymore
that's carried thank you
it's closed we will
everybody comfortable good right we'll
move
[Applause]
okay dc
20 05 137 land at cobwebs farm ipsy
drove had the ipswich suffolk
um i would invite the case officer to
introduce this item
chair do we do we want to begin the
debate on this or should we just
well pause it because of what's happened
on the last one
mr chairman do we need a full
introduction if um
because this is linked to the previous
application which we've deferred this
in which case i propose we defer this
application and save the case officer
from presenting
something that we're not actually going
to listen to do sorry about that
can we have advice about whether that
would count as a deferral or is it just
does it just not feature because you
haven't even started
discussing it yet i don't know what its
legal status would be for example
i think we want to include it in the
site visit for the other one as well
you might as well do them both at the
same time
but this this stands on its own two feet
if we're not
on if we're not careful it doesn't have
to hinge on the foot previously
so so yes sorry counselor yeah must be
suggesting a site visit for this one as
well so
it's orange i just think it makes sense
to do a site
site visits for this one the same as the
other one
i mean yes at the moment we have the map
of this do you want to
before we do anything more deferred
is that legal well i think chairman and
the committee can
vote to do whatever it likes within
reason
um i i agree i mean i think
some would suggest you ought to hear
something but then i think you can
exercise common sense and say well if
we've
we've been told that everyone agrees
it's linked
to the matter that we've that's just
been deferred for a site visit
i mean it's i'm trying to think of
recent precedence we've had of this sort
of thing i
i don't think we've i don't think we
need insist that there'd be a full
presentations
in my view and mr chairman the sa
it's the same applicant isn't it and yep
he's he's in the room he's heard what's
been said i i'm quite sure
that um he understands at this
point that we've got to on this and um
i would have thought you know he's not
jumping up and down inside he wants to
hear
it no no i accept that what do we
do i think i think if if there's a
problem
yes oh yes we i think we must have a
resolution i must have a proposal and a
second
i'll propose mr chairman the same that i
did earlier
that we have defer this and have a site
inspection that can all happen at the
same time thank you
i'm sorry okay
a repeat player
members the vote is the application dc
2005 137 be deferred an order of the
chief planning
officer to arrange a member site visit
following the
protocol as this item is linked to the
first one
okay i'll just put that in
so if you go into your modgult app
select attendance and voting
this vote is now in progress
thank you members chair that's eight
votes four and one against
it's carried there we are ladies
gentlemen thank you for your attendance
that's the end of the meeting
sorry check before we go could that if
possible could i ask the applicant
for this for the next report
it would be useful to know what kind of
employment
you would anticipating being on this
site
i think just putting e or b2 or
something doesn't really mean a great
deal if you've got somebody in mind or
somebody that's interested that would be
useful
but happy to do it again
looks like it will have no business
but we're fun
it could be a site visit we'll we'll
wait and see um
nope i'm saving that for the cake
john
you